quel visage aura le rassemblement
national pour 2022 avec marine le pen
à sa tête on en parle avec nos deux
invités que c'est le débat de ce soir et
nous sommes avec françois cocq et
céistes ex orateur à la france insoumise
et emeric et glissait secrétaire général
adjoint du think tank millénaire bonsoir
messieurs et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur arte france à l'échec du rnb
aux régionales a entraîné des critiques
en interne notamment sur la
normalisation du parti visiblement pas
de quoi bousculer marine le pen puisque
on le rappelle à vient d'être réélu à
98% des voix à la tête du parti son
poulain jordan bardella a été lui le
mieux élu au conseil national du rnd
vendée historiques comme louis aliot ou
bien steeve briois c'est lui jordan
bardella qui est désigné et premier
vice-président du mouvement il reprendra
les rênes du parti en septembre le temps
de la présidentielle des décisions et
des votes qui acte de fait aux internes
le renouveau du rnd brigue glis et c'est
un veau qui confieront le choix de la
stratégie de marine le pen que la
normalisation alors on pouvait peut-être
s'attendre à un retour en arrière c'est
notamment ce qu avait exprimé dans les
médias jean-marie le pen parce que j'ai
en fait finalement on la défaite aux
régionales
c'est un point important dans le chemin
et la stratégie qu'avait voka marine le
pen elle avait dit que justement les
besoins de gagner des régions pour
préparer des atouts et des alliés pour
ensuite pouvoir in fine est gouvernée
accède à l'elysée pouvoir appliquer son
programme dans les territoires
finalement elle a perdu c'est une
défaite qui est importante à la fois
d'un point de vue électoral et d'un
point de vue stratégique
ça marche que la nhtsa montrent que la
normalisation finalement n'a pas permis
de réduire le vote de barrage les
français et les parties se sont
mobilisés de la même façon pour faire
barrage au front national et dans le
même temps elle a perdu des électeurs
des acteurs sont moins mobilisés d'un
électorat qui était davantage
révolutionnaire qui voulaient se
mobiliser contre le système qui peut
exprimer une certaine colère n'a plus
retrouvé dans les propositions dans
discours du front national cette colère
et cette façon de s'exprimer
donc ils service est retranché dans
l'abstention donc marine le pen continue
sur ces stratégies
finalement donc pense que ça va aboutir
à peu près à la même chose qu'en 2017
c'est à dire un échec pour le front
national et on pense même qu'elle sera
pas au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle
en fait on a mené une étude on
s'aperçoit que a priori un an avant
chaque élection présidentielle le front
national a des intentions de vote
10% supérieur à son score réel donc elle
a eu un pic à peu près il ya un mois à
28 28 %
donc on estime qu'elle finira finalement
entre 18 et 20% et par rapport aux
intentions de vote à la fois d'une
gauche qui pourrait être unis ou d'une
droite républicaine et d'emmanuel macron
l'espace pour le front national en
réalité est plutôt fin pour se qualifier
au second tour et celle dynamique est
déjà en cours de tassement en un mois
marine le pen a déjà perdu 4 % dans les
intentions de vote
donc non je pense que cette dynamique va
haute-loire phase prolongée
on va continuer a décroché en partie sur
l'électorat qui est plutôt a politisé
l'abstention pourra également jouer
adjoint à rolle et une fille dérens
qualifiera pas au second tour de la
présidentielle quel est aujourd'hui elle
selon vous francs 50 la ligne du r n est
qu elle différente à ce que vous voyez
avec le fn d'il ya quelques années
qu'est-ce que de ce que donne à voir ce
finalement ce congrès de perpignan du
rassemblement national c'est que le
rassemblement national est devenu un
parti comme un autre dans sa gestion
politique c'est à dire que nous avons eu
un congrès là on en pendant plusieurs
jours qui n'a traité que d'un terne
marine le pen a fait ainsi que la récré
en interne mais elle ne s'est pas occupé
de ce qu'ont dit les français il ya
quelques semaines ou plutôt de ce qu'ils
n'ont pas dit il ne vous aura pas
échappé que dans son intervention cet
après midi elle a totalement contourner
l'obstacle
à l'image de monsieur macro et elle a
fait comme si ces régionales n'avait pas
eu lieu
elle ne veux pas en tirer les
conséquences ni des résultats électoraux
en tant que telle ni de l'abstention qui
a frappé le front national comme il a
frappé des autres partis et autres
mouvements
autrement dit cette abstention qui
frappa à la fois le pouvoir en place
mais également l'ensemble des
oppositions
elle donne à voir l'impuissance de
l'ensemble du champ politique actuelle
et le rassemblement national lui est
encore plus frappés par seize papa par
sept par cette impuissance que e
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui n'existe et
n'a de chances d'être réélu à l'elysée
temps se posant en recours contre le
front national autrement dit c'est le
rassemblement national lui
mais qui nourrit emmanuel macron que les
français veulent faire sortir de
l'elysée
le rassemblement national en tant que
tel et un obstacle et cette question là
n'a pas été traitée dans le cadre du du
congrès du rassemblement national
c'est resté une question interne entre
le front national dit hier le
rassemblement national d'aujourd'hui ou
de demain
et finalement les préoccupations des
français sont si vous le permettez
passer à l'as une fois de plus donc ce
qu est ce qui se donne à voir
aujourd'hui c'est finalement un
prolongement de l'existant vous avez vu
les personnalités qui sont sortis de
ceux de ce congrès monsieur bardella on
continue dans le népotisme qui a
toujours été la marque de fabrique du
rassemblement national puisque celui là
est le neveu par alliance de madame le
pen
et finalement ce sont les mêmes cadres
qui sont reconduits avec une forme de
déresponsabilisation politique là même
qui est celle que leur assemblée
nationale voudrait faire porter à juste
titre sur emmanuel macron le
gouvernement avait plusieurs ministres
engagés aux régionales
tous ont été battus voir la mine et il
n'y a eu aucune conséquence politique
pour cela et bien au rassemblement
national c'est exactement la même chose
monsieur bardella a perdu 5 points entre
2015 et 2021 aux régionales il a reculé
entre le premier et le deuxième tour et
le voilà promu président par intérim du
rassemblement national de même pour
julian ou double qui n'a pas gagné un
point entre le premier et le second tour
en bourgogne franche comté qui devient
porte parole de ceux de ce mouvement
c'est finalement le prolongement de
l'existant qui ce qui se poursuit qui
s'ancre en dépit de la dynamique inverse
qui fera qu'aujourd'hui ce mouvement car
marine le pen a évoqué cet après midi et
a lors de son discours une victoire
idéologique totale en faisant allusion à
la reprise de certaines thématiques vrm
par d'autres formations politiques quel
est votre sentiment sur ce point
aimerait glissait on a en fait en
réalité un double phénomène parc on a un
phénomène finalement le rl c'est s'est
normalisée sur beaucoup de thématiques
notamment notamment régaliennes la
droite a de son côté un peu plus musclé
son discours notamment au fait que le
bloc central des manuels maquereau ou un
fait de toutes façons pousser les partis
de gouvernement soient de gauche comme
de droite a abordé des thématiques qui
soit un peu plus un peu plus radicales
pour exister face au bloc au bloc
central
et donc on a sept 7 cette situation
finalement sur le sur le volet régalien
l'immigration n'a pas réellement de
différences en termes de propositions
entre le r ndlr une forme plutôt de
continuité il ya en tout cas pas de
rupture franche et sur le sur le volet
économique et tient des thèses qui sont
maintenant il ya on parle plus du tout
sortie de l'euro on est sur des
thématiques et sont plutôt de centre
droit ou de voir des fois de
centre-gauche et donc on ne sait pas
forcément les thématiques de rennes caen
gagner c'est simplement le rl qui s'est
normalisée une recomposition politique
qui a eu lieu autour d'un bloc central
qui a poussé les partis de gouvernement
à avoir des positionnements qui soit un
peu plus radicaux et important qui est
intéressant à laquelle le prince n'est
pas revenu la question de l'abstention
comme comme le disait un instant à juste
titre le front national avait exhorté
ses sympathisants à venir voter au
second tour
et ils ont finalement ensuite expliqué
que s'il avait échoué aux régions c'est
à cause de l'abstention en réalité
lorsque robert notamment une étude ifop
les français des conversations des
français entre le premier second tour 66
% des français ont parlé de l'abstention
au premier tour donc il était au courant
des élections au courant du sujet de
l'abstention ils ne sont quand même pas
aller voter
en réalité ces électeurs finalement
feront pas fait le déplacement pour le
front national et qui étaient des
électeurs marine le pen en 2017 se sont
détournés de fondasol et ne veulent plus
voter au foot au fonds national
actuellement parce qu'ils n'avaient pas
aux attentes
le front national de 2017 c'est une
réponse aux attentes et à la colère
identitaire et sociale
aujourd'hui elle raconte ni à la colère
l'identitaire en ces temps normalisé ni
à la colère sociale économique puisque
de toute façon emmanuel macron
appliquant à quoi qu'il en coûte
le débat économique la la la la colère
sociale est plutôt suta qui actuellement
est dans le même temps on apprend retour
de ces questions économiques et sociales
sur lesquelles marine le pen n'est pas
crédible
on l'a vu avec le débat du second tour
toutes les thématiques et toute la
stratégie et tout ce qui est en train de
se mettre en place d'ici 2022 plutôt
être au désavantage du front national et
on devrait continuer vers une baisse
tendancielle du front national
c'est pourquoi et compter sur davantage
sur une stratégie de rente beaucoup de
conquêtes alors jordan bardella sur
cette thématique de la présidentielle
dans moins d'un an a déclaré hier
rien n'est perdu il ya encore un chemin
vers la victoire qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire françois cocq tout d'abord que
le rassemblement national a perdu la
main à un moment donné vous l'évoquiez
il ya un instant il rassemble nationale
pourrait surfer sur une forme
d'hégémonie culturelle puisque
aujourd'hui les thématiques qui sont
dans le débat public sont des
thématiques qui pourraient être
porteuses pour le rassemblement national
or il a perdu la main sur celle ci et on
voit bien que finalement il n'est plus
maître du destin et de son destin
électoral est il à la merci de ce que va
décider la droite et de la capacité qu'a
le droit ou non à être aujourd'hui et
demain en dynamique c'est le premier
aspect le deuxième aspect c'est que
monsieur bardella peut bien dire que le
soleil brillera eux demain mais il
devrait faire le constat que pour
l'instant ce sont des nuages et même un
orage assez violent qui s'est abattu sur
sur sur son mouvement et il ya deux
raisons à cela
la première c'est l'absence de cohérence
jusqu'à présent le rassemblement était
identifiée par les électeurs comme un
mouvement qui suivait une ligne des
raids directrice nantes en penser ce
qu'on se comprend pas c'est pour ma part
je la combattrai mais en tout cas qui
avait le mérite d'être toujours la même
il s'avère que ça a été monté il ya un
instant des ruptures importantes sont
intervenus sur la question de l'europe
et de l'euro madame le pen vient de
signer un communiqué où il appelle à
réformer l'europe réforme et l'europe
c'est un vocabulaire absolument
absolument nouveau et un lissage nouveau
l appel à rembourser la dette issue du
duc au vide autrement dit sur tous ces
aspects là le rassemblement national
fait des zigzags permanent et a perdu sa
cohérence en vous savez dans la période
dans ce moment de crise démocratique où
les gens veulent qu'on leur donne des
gages les citoyens veulent reprendre le
contrôle vous savez que la cohérence et
la nouvelle radicalité et donc de ce
point de vue là le rassemblement
national est en retrait est sanctionné
en cela par les françaises et les
français
et puis le deuxième point c'est que le
rassemblement national s'est
institutionnalisée totalement ces
dernières années à partir de 2017
il a joué totalement le jeu
parlementaire en oubliant d'aller en
direction des français et hans
institutionnalisant il est il s'est
vautré dans le juge
électoral qui est un jeu dans lequel il
n'y a plus aucune dynamique est la seule
dynamique qui existe aujourd'hui dans ce
pays
c'est une dynamique qui est hors du
champ institutionnel c'est la dynamique
populaire qui s'est exprimé au moment dé
gilet jaune c'est celle qu'on a
retrouvés avec des solides arrêt
solidarité replier qui ont émané de tous
les toutes les françaises et tous les
français pendant la crise qu vide et le
rassemblement national est passé à côté
de ça il ya une majorité populaire qui
existe dans ce pays
à une époque le rassemblement national
prétendait la chevauchée et bien il est
passé à côté de celle ci et celle ci
existe pourtant encore il faudra bien
que quelqu'un lui donne un débouché
humaniste et qui permettent de rendre de
refonder le peuple est de reconstruire
le pays merci à tous les deux messieurs
le ton fils c'est la fin de ce débat
malheureusement on aura évidemment
l'occasion d'aborder à nouveau cette
thématique merci françois cocq essayiste
et ex orateur à la france ont soumis des
mre glissait secrétaire général adjoint
du think tank le millénaire merci
beaucoup et à bientôt sur arte france